is interesting during halftime with VP
of basketball operations Magic Johnson
courtside Smith punches at home and
that's kind of the midair pyrotechnics
that he's provided throughout his young
basketball career with junior can I add
to the hype Jeff sure you're looking at
the winner of the slam dunk contest in
February
[Applause]
do that they call the jam it is up Hawks
soaring and scoring and thing a beauty
Anna Smith jr. the Maverick sent by
seven for the Hawks signal one surprise
that he seems to play the game this was
galaxy's first offensive possession
everything went perfectly the pass was
great the screen set was really good in
and out for Harris
the well stays answering
[Music]
[Applause]
this high-speed replay brought to you by
AT&T Nowell the offensive rebound of the
big jam that was provocative to be the
white collar guy though - oh wow
Smith baseline raring back and here he
is cleared for takeoff there was no shot
blocker getting anywhere near that one
big dunk by Smith the night for Smith
three-point Drive my wall is no good
leaking out and hammering it home
boos and aahs all heard throughout
Capital One Arena long shot long rebound
West bad news up to Dennis Smith junior
and watch this elevation boom throwing
it down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
speaking steel
[Applause]
Wow
did you submit jr. Hartman yeah this is
really provocative and I got you guys
going to tell the people was especially
a great first step and then the
elevation Junior
[Applause]
the rookie is going on elevation for
game ever gained out of the timeout for
Denver yogi to the basket with the
answer and with an answer that results
and gasps and oohs and ahhs and timber
here's the dunk this is that call set
called clear out clear out that the
young man do what he does best
clear out take off mr. dark three-game
wild with Dallas against the Wizards
he's averaged
yet to come back to this shout out to
you right there probably was a time
where skin could dunk
oh yeah the basketball but never
that will promise you that he'll never
be out there crying that's the Shabaab
oh here he goes
we'll take off
against Richardson looking at crossover
and once you get beat by him it's over
for you it's Curtis yeah cuz he's so
quick in the three overall fits by
Boston and Dennis Smith is Smith you
know what that missed that week with
major hip surgery the seven-month
recovery takes some time to work back
from that shows off the 48 48 inch
vertical with the finishes that's good
that for long
Hardaway jr. on the drive ripped away
easy chance to score
yep isn't it a shame
New York tonight love to watch the
what's the bench in the background there
couldn't see from that angle but they're
all standing up at midcourt cuz recent
bump on the road losing five out of six
well what makes this team successful
isn't look at this mark look out here
comes with a 360 breakaway dunk field
from dsj I like it I've never in my life
been able to 360 on a duck so that's
impressive
I think his effect on this team really
growing well moving forward
what changed by Smith he drives he spins
he elevates and grabs it home to the
floor early on there's the spin and a
slam dunk we saw a moment ago a timeout
of the floor
[Applause]
to pitch logic for on this dock our
distributive oh man
that's gonna break the Internet Wow
let's watch mom make your mom not my
10th pick up on the floor one guy we
won't see on the floor but we get see
how the bench Luca da judge who watches
this from
here's the play from the Blackman miss
taking the other way Dennis Smith junior
to the rack and a flush quick outlet for
Smith the three is no good there's no
question about it when you miss a jump
shot you know better than anyone where
it's gonna come off he was in the right
place at the right time I'm seeing
almost push back
[Applause]
oh yeah just got around Russell that's
where the explosion comes in just out
jumped everybody out quick to everybody
and kind of self easy to on the jam 16
points per game this season just had a
stretch where he missed four out of five
games with a hamstring injury
tell you attack mad at that Ram as he
throws it down its sleep today to get
ready for this one but the second one
back to Mecca nonetheless Smith all the
way in for the two-handed Jam after the
dunk or just blew right by the Anthony
Melton Wow shoot that was probably
wasn't expecting that pass after that
one well the courage to go back in there
sooner or later I'm gonna get you and
Randall
that'll make posters anymore but and
four assists today is looking for more
nights still sniff after a 360 slams at
home
nice defense myth Jim Jordan altered
that shop Dixit play good interior deep
watch dinner Smith folks did not witness
to have that turned deadly wine
Oh beautiful steel Oh
Smith with a tomahawk that was quite
asked that steel and there's this strip
[Applause]
you